this is nick gillespie for reason since
the election of Donald Trump we've been
talking to libertarian policy experts
about what a trump presidency will bring
to health care education foreign policy
and the justice system the people we
talked to our Michael canon of the Cato
Institute Lisa Graham Keegan former head
of education in Arizona historian
Thaddeus Russell legal scholar Randy
Barnett and defense attorney and legal
blogger Ken white Pope add to our
surprise the mood is one of skeptical
optimism all agree that Trump is likely
to hand off the details of policy and
day-to-day operations to his cabinet
secretaries and administrators in many
cases those people are almost certain to
be preferable to one selected by Hillary
Clinton and even when they are not
there's reason to believe that a
resurgent Congress and bureaucratic
inertia will put a stop to Trump's worst
desires here are excerpts from recent
recent podcasts to hear the full
conversations subscribe to the reason
podcast at iTunes and don't forget to
rate and review us to start things off I
talked with Thaddius Russell author of a
renegade history of the United States
and a forthcoming book on American
foreign policy Russell started out by
talking about how Trump's new foreign
policy team is far less interventionist
than the people Hillary Clinton would
have named in foreign policy you know
they can drop bombs you know in the next
hour when we have no say over it so that
was really terrifying for me but now
it's pretty clear that the people he has
assembled around him on foreign policy
do have a fairly coherent and consistent
idea about it which is to withdraw
militarily from the world in general not
entirely not entirely now they do want
as he is repeatedly to bomb the [ __ ] out
of Isis I don't see any diff there among
them um but it seems to be limited to
that and you know the number one issue
for me and the election was whether we
were going to go to war with Russia I
mean no one seemed to care except for
the Liberals toward the end who were
actually calling for war with Russia but
to me that was really terrifying Russia
is a declining power but it does still
have the second largest military in the
world and hillary was clearly calling
for war with Russia that's what no-fly
zone constitutes it meant shooting down
Russian planes if they didn't stand down
and in Syria she was
calling for a no-fly zone where Russian
planes are essentially patrolling the
skies for Bashar al-assad the dictator
or president whatever leader of Syria do
you so you're happy and I like the way
that you're putting it that you know
isolationism is okay when it comes to
foreign policy with trade and
immigration and kind of other kinds of
cultural ties with the world it's got
too [ __ ] up are damned do you how who
are his advisors can you talk a little
bit about that and why does that fill
you with kind of you know a sense of
calm that they actually do want to pull
back America's military footprint from
the world someone yes this is
fascinating so I started to do I had
done some research on this during a
campaign but I really did a deep dive
when I saw reports last night that Newt
Gingrich was going to be his Secretary
of State um which immediately has told
me oh my god the neo-cons are going to
take over in fact that was that was my
main concern about Trump is that there
was gonna be basically a vacuum in the
foreign policy establishment because he
knows nothing about the world and would
depend on advisors so my fear was that
the same thing would happen that
happened with Bush right which was that
the neocon saw this opportunity and
lepton it and took over and ran us into
the ground that's not been happening in
this case in fact as anyone who's
followed it knows the neo-cons hate
Trump's guts which was run reasons why
isn't it they were good never Trumper's
really i mean the both the hawks a
national review and especially a weekly
standard yeah so this is fantastic news
for us in the world and so Newt Gingrich
everyone should read he did an inner
very lengthy interview with The
Washington Times or examiner I forget
which one in 2013 in which Heath
thoroughly aggressively repudiated
neoconservatism and foreign military
interventions generally he gets a robust
isolationist argument in that interview
and he repeated it on Sean Hannity in
May of this year
uh to Sean Hannity's face he said the
Bush Doctrine was a disaster he said
even the Afghanistan war has given us
nothing he said the Iraq war was a
terrible mistake we have lost blood and
treasure to these things he calls for a
withdrawal from he says the United
States should stop thinking about
exporting democracy because that project
has not worked I mean it was a
phenomenal thing now Newt Gingrich is
associate hath generally and it could
have been you know if he had been
sitting in the same position for 30
minutes as blood sugar might have spiked
we don't know if this actually
represents what he thinks on a full
belly right so but so so who knows but
it's odd that he would choose that for
political advantage in 2013 I don't know
what serve his purpose then and he
repeated it three years later on Sean
Hannity's show on Fox News yeah then so
then I thought well maybe this is just a
one-off within his foreign policy
advisors no it's not true so that the
core and this is really interesting the
core apparently in Trump's foreign
policy ideas comes from this guy who's
30 years old named Steven Miller who is
jeff's essen sessions as a main aid
informant made advisor on foreign policy
sessions has sort of taken the role of
the lead role in Trump's foreign policy
team this time Miller is a 30 year old
guy kid Jewish from Santa Monica went to
Santa Monica High School which is where
my son goes mm-hmm his mentor Miller's
mentor is David Horowitz the notorious
ex-communist who became a right-winger
in the 1980s whose son was a friend of
mine at Berkeley High School that anyway
Horowitz now Horowitz is a catastrophe
when it comes to Middle East policy and
I think Trump's policy will be either
equally as bad as Obama's or worse well
and can I also point out that David
Horowitz wrote a book that came out 68
69 70 something like that new world
Colossus which was one of the great
Summa pieces an indictment from a new
left position of American foreign policy
as a form of imperialism and obviously
he
he grew on from that to becoming really
the cartoon version the gargoyle version
of himself in politics so here as I
understand is for with his main
difference from the nyoka the main
neo-cons which is that they all agree
that every Arabic who has bad feelings
about Israel should be destroyed
tomorrow however they Horowitz is seems
to be only interested in that area in
protecting Israel and destroying Arab
opposition to Israel I do know for sure
because Miller has said this many many
times his protege Miller who's trump's
main advisor and foreign policy
apparently for many reports is only
interested in attacking Isis and wants
the United States to withdraw from the
West rest of the world generally on top
of that there is consistency among
sessions Miller and Gingrich antrim that
we should the United States should
cooperate with Russia rather than fight
Russia now that definitely made me sleep
better last night but it's not the
greatest thing in the whole world
because what they're calling for is a
joint Russian u.s. operation against
Isis which is essentially a multilateral
escalation of the war on terror right
however the good news there may be is
that you know many analysts of the
region are saying that Isis may not
survive as a military organization after
by the time Trump is an office there you
know they're being destroyed right now
in the cities and as an effective
organization there may be nothing to
bomb the [ __ ] out of by the time Trump
gets there there will always be an Isis
you know as long as the United States is
intervening in the Middle East and some
form or another mostly in little cells
around the world which you know that
could be the endless war still but I
don't see with Trump right now I really
don't i don't see a war with Russia and
I don't see a greater interventionism
generally outside of that little pocket
of the Middle East so and in the piece
that you read for reason about Hillary
Clinton and I think the exact title is
something like Hillary Clinton's
dangerously coherent foreign policy you
talked about how Donald Trump will
definitely be worse or almost certainly
would be worse in the middle
than Hillary Clinton but that would be
the limit of it because Hillary Clinton
actually does have this thought through
kind of systemic or systemic foreign
policy that she talked about in the last
or one of the presidential debates about
how you know we really have to go
everywhere and pay any price kind of
Cold War mentality that the US has to be
at the at every battle over the you know
anywhere in the world so you're saying
essentially that Trump is the kind of
the answer to that yeah well the word
that they use that the Trump people
Miller Gingrich such use is globalism
that's their enemy yeah so you know
again these guys are isolationist they
really this is so traumatic then let's
let's talk about this a little bit
because you know you also mentioned so
Jeff Sessions is having a an outsized
influence on Trump's foreign policy he's
also the architect of trumps immigration
policy and he's you know the worst
person in the world certainly in the
Senate about immigration and about
getting rid of people he shown he's the
senator from Alabama he doesn't care
about rounding up illegals who were
helping to you know Alabama businesses
and wards and what not to you know bring
their crops to market he is and he hates
immigrants apparently he hates
intervention he's not a free trader is
there a way to separate out you know say
the non-interventionism or the
isolationism of Trump from those other
things because if we do get a new
smoot-hawley you know high tariffs if we
do create endless trade wars with
countries if we're in the Middle East
partnering with Russia I mean you know
ken this can this actually turn out well
for America as a nation well like I said
this is this is about what the president
actually has the power to do so in
foreign policy he has tremendous
autonomous power and that's what's so
dangerous and by the way then POW
basically been given two presidents
under the most liberal president's right
this is Wilson Rosa Johnson and Obama in
particular it can but not all of them
all of them did in the 20th century but
those in particular expanded executive
power
in particular in foreign policy so
that's really the danger and we need to
be critiquing that every single day we
need to be reducing that power the
president has in foreign policy but so
this is very good news that mean that
where Trump has the most power is where
he is closest to our position right so
or what about what about you know let's
talk about Russia is it simply that
contemporary foreign policy strategists
and theorists and and policymakers is it
that they are simply still locked
they've never moved on from the cold war
effectively where you know there's
Russia and the rest of Europe we know
what side were on were in NATO which did
not disband after the Soviet Union
collapsed and you know is it going to
sit well with them that we suddenly if
if Donald Trump is like you know what I
don't really give a [ __ ] about Russia
and their ambitions you know within a
European sphere of influence or other
places yeah there's going to be a new
fight and it's going to be fascinating
to watch this will only be in Washington
DC which is in but it will be the Clint
onian Obama wilsonian Democrats which is
most of the Democrats versus the these
Trump isolationists yeah so I mean the
Democrats and a wing of the Republican
Party who are still interventionist as
yellow where does somebody like Dick
Cheney Dick Cheney was one of the few
Republicans and I think he was the only
Republican vice president who's still
alive who was like yeah I'm voting for
Trump and I'm not apologizing for it and
yet he was by many accounts the
architect of George Bush's
interventionism says he would do it
again in a heartbeat never seem to have
a problem with sending other people into
war that where is he in in this kind of
scheme of things yeah I mean such a nice
hard to read on this actually I always I
was never convinced that he was actually
a globalist I was I think he may have
been more in the Horowitz camp of just
wanting to protect Israel um or just
aura of securing the Middle East right
and securing the flow of what I think
Cheney was in some ways kissing Jerian
realist and that he just wanted the
United States to maintain it
its power geopolitically and to maintain
control that oil supply can I ask is
there how do you make America great
again which for all of the 20th century
or certainly after world war one in
world war two that was contained
contingent on us being the greatest
military power in the world it does
Trump understand that make America great
again then if he's if he suck him at a
version where it's he's making America
rich again perhaps or he thinks it is by
cutting it off from the world but isn't
great isn't national greatness kind of
tied up in the idea of the projection of
American military power around the globe
yeah i mean that's that's the way that
the the DC elites have thought of it for
about a century yeah this is true uh
you're right and he's running counter to
that so and and you just let me just to
kind of get your sense on this he's also
talked about how we're going to have the
best weapons you know we're going to
have the newest weapons we're gonna have
the shiniest weapons he said he would
break the sequester which took a you
know a nickel and a dime out of the
pentagon budget for a year you know is
he does I guess what I'm asking is and
you've said that you when you look at it
he's actual there's a coherence behind
it but does he understand there's a
coherence behind it or is this just kind
of where he throws a lot of stuff into
the pot and then hopes that it makes us
do that you can stomach because yeah how
do you know why would we if we're
returning if we're pulling back from the
world would we be pulling back basis
would that be seen as a retreat by him
what happens when Putin moves in fully
into the Ukraine or start sticking
around with other parts you know the the
Balkans Baltic States will that be seen
as an insult that needs to be avenged no
I think he'll let Putin have what he
wants in Eastern Europe I don't find
that's pretty consistent by the way
there's another major foreign policy of
buzzer for Trump that everyone should
look on a michael Flynn who was one of
the head of the intelligence division
under Obama who was fired by the Obama
administration for blowing the whistle
on Obama arming the bad guys in Syria
and so he's actually been a regular
guest on RT network over here and has
made very friendly noises about Putin
and so it's pretty they're pretty
consistent on this amazing be the
derrick and they're going to be very
cooperative with Putin talk you'll if
you could talk a little bit about is
there I do you proceed from a position
that foreign policy is not a place for
kind of individual morality or that the
language of morality when applied to
foreign policy is used almost
exclusively to get us into stupid and
unwinnable situations but one of the
arguments that you know people
anti-trump asst talk about is that you
know he's awful he'll give all of this
power and all of this leeway to Putin
who is a tyrant who is going who's
already destroying his own country and
is on the March and that because we have
certain commitments to the Baltic States
to to post-soviet nations in the former
Soviet Union that we would be reneging
on American exceptionalism if we just
turned a blind eye to let Putin and
Europe kind of fight its own battles yes
we would so my whole book that I'm
working on that basically the argument
is against yes you're right at its base
this these moral claims that have made
about been made about the world by the
architects of American foreign policy
for the last hundred and twenty thirty
years there's this amazing thing that
happened at the turn of the 20th century
where a lot of American elites said we
are actually obligated to uplift not
just our own people but everyone all
over the world we lay claim to every
piece of land on Earth and so whenever
there is a dictator or tyrant we don't
like who doesn't do who does things that
we don't like any part of the world we
are obligated to remove him that has
been the the strategy the intention the
world plan for every president except
for a handful since then and that has
led us into killing several million
civilian
and about a half a million Americans in
the process and doing great damage
otherwise now Trump is the first
president he is the first president to
call [ __ ] on that very claim that we
have anymore have any moral standing any
moral reason any obligation to help
anyone in the rest of the world and in
doing so I think he may do great service
for actual piece believe it or not so
talk if you can how did this play out in
you know kind of present in primary
politics it's it's clear that you know
Republicans in general are you know have
been hawkish for a long time at least
you know Nixon or you know as a counter
to McGovern was the piece neck
Republicans especially under Reagan and
since Reagan up and you know bully boys
for war Democrats go back and forth and
Bernie Sanders obviously not a Democrat
running as a Democrat an independent was
very critical of of Hillary Clinton's
foreign policy and but then he he folded
the tent on that when he got his fifteen
dollar minimum wage and free college in
state college tuition and he never
really mentioned foreign policy again is
there a sizable group in the Democratic
Party that actually will have to
understand that there with Trump there
with him on this and are there
Republicans who are not you know there's
I've met a lot of kind of old rightist
types who are yeah you know we should
never been in the first Gulf War much
less the invasion of Iraq in 2003 how is
this going to play out because it's
going to fit the cognitive dissonance
here is pretty staggering yeah within
the Democratic Party I see almost no
evidence that they will go along with
Trump on foreign policy in fact all I
have seen in the last year is people in
the Democratic Party being horrified
that Trump wants to quote withdraw from
the world or quote support Putin's
intentions in the middle in the Eastern
Europe or in the Middle East I they have
always been globalists and by the way
this thing about George McGovern being
the peace candidate is about F [ __ ]
so George McGovern if you actually
look at his career and his ideas about
the world he was a globalist he was a
moralistic globalist wilsonian always
his problem with the Vietnam War was the
same problem that Obama had with Iraq
which was not the United States
shouldn't do these wars across the world
but they should do them intelligently
that Vietnam was an unintelligent war
that was self-destructive it was
actually was actually harming the it was
actually harming the project of American
imperialism it was discredited States oh
bond that was Obama's critique of the
rock right no and so these guys in
Clinton and by the way Bernie's the same
same way he wants to influence the whole
world through four and eight primarily
globalist but he also wants to continue
the drum bore so he's laying claim to
the way people live across the world as
well I don't see any truly anti
wilsonian anti globalist faction in the
Democratic Party do you think that Trump
is you know and not at this is not a
temperament question per se but is he is
he capable of following you know a line
of thought in policy and we don't know i
mean you know there's some suggestions
from his business practices and whatnot
i suppose we could look at but he's
never held office or is he going to be
the dog that is constantly seeing a red
you know a flash of red somewhere in
chasing after different things because
on the one hand ii it literally says you
know we're going to bomb the [ __ ] out of
isis on the other hand he's like hey you
know what we shouldn't even be involved
in this so yeah i mean you're betting
that he and the team of divisors and the
policy makers that he's put around him
are going to be pretty consistent on
this well i mean yeah i mean at least in
the people he brought around him about
on foreign policy they'd they are
coherent and consistent at least i will
say over the last year or two I mean
Hugh Ingrid before 2013 was a nightmare
alrighty but yeah you know recently has
been very very good actually what is the
appeal of you know to the extent and I
don't think it's fully clear the you
know the capsule summary of this
election is that Trump won by appealing
to white working-class people less
educated people you know obviously
racist and sexist and homophobic and
xenophobic and you know just terrible
human being
is there reason to believe that they
also support an end to overseas
intervention because when you look at
certain surveys of kind of white
working-class votes they're the ones you
know winning wars overseas and being
able to send their kids off to be blown
into torsos you know and to spill blood
on Florence and that's that's part of
why they love America is there a reason
to believe that you know these these
people who you know provide the bodies
for Wars really also we're saying yeah
that's part of what I like about Trump
yeah so the idea that we have a moral
claim to moral obligation to uplift the
world comes out of universities this is
this is the passives came up with that
idea these were all academics basically
are people who you know were bred in the
elite Ivy League schools right Trump's
base was who it was non-college educated
people I actually think this election
was in primarily about a battle between
the hardcore Trump supporters who were
non-college educated people not
acculturated to that world in which we
all talk about the poor people of the
world what we must do to save them and
you know and appeal who come from my
world right these these liberal elite
colleges who have these grandiose ideas
about uplifting the savages I think that
was actually the battle that we just had
and I think I think the people outside
of colleges won this battle and at least
a foreign policy I think that's a good
thing talk a little bit about how can
America or you know and maybe you you
think that you know just as we don't
have a military a path to you know
bettering the world ever we shouldn't
use the military we shouldn't be overly
concerned with the rest of the world
that I know that you like the idea of
America is a place where you know people
pour in and out and kind of mix and
hybridize and mongrel eyes and you know
that free trade and free immigration or
migration of people is a good thing what
are the ways absent military
intervention and kind of old-style
foreign aid which everybody knows
doesn't work what are the ways that
America can actually have a
official effect on parts of the world
where people are either not doing so
well or are in you know despotic regimes
where they're simply not allowed to
actually express themselves in any
meaningful way simple open borders and
free trade that is that has always been
the answer you know when the Jews in the
1930s were asking to come into the
United States the United States said
sorry right that would have been the
answer to the Holocaust if the united
states in the West had opened their
borders that would've been the answer at
the very same time inside the Nazi
Germany there was a gigantic love of
jazz music and Hollywood movies that the
Nazis desperately were trying to
suppress which they couldn't because
they knew that people love that stuff
that pleasure in that freedom in those
musical forms in that part form much
more than the discipline that the Nazis
require right the United States never
even occurred to them right to just call
for free trade in that they wanted to
free trade in other ways but not in what
was really bringing down authoritarian
regimes same thing happened in the
Soviet Union same thing is happening in
Iran right now same thing is happening
in Saudi Arabia same thing is happening
in a rock the the products of our
popular culture is what those regimes
are actually most worried about that's
what really subverts them from within
and all we need to do we don't need any
policy at all except a lack of policy we
need no policies governing the borders
no policies governing trade let it go
and the people will be free I am a fond
of saying that you know there's at least
one revolution named after the velvet
underground and absolutely none named
after Van Cliburn who was America's high
culture export during the Cold War and I
think you're onto something let me ask a
final question so you know that's your
vision of you know let let them in and
let people let people come here let
people flourish let people mix Trump is
antithetical to that in a way and and
say with the Syrian refugees this is one
of the things that drives me nuts about
him is to the extent that he recognizes
we [ __ ] up the middle east and he said
at various points whether he's talking
about Libya or Iraq or Syria at various
points he said you know we we destroyed
this place and then heat but then at the
same time he's like oh and we're
definitely not letting any Syrians and
because they're all you know they all
hate us because we destroyed their
homeland what you know how is is there a
way that you're looking towards getting
him to understand you can have one or
the other you know you can retreat from
the world but invite people into your
house or you know that it it's kind of a
terrible thing to you know go into a
region and destroy it and then tell
people sorry you're not allowed in the
country that helped d sterilize your
entire life yeah by the way you know
unfortunately that is that trumps
argument about the refugees is is
actually the argument taken up by a lot
of right-wing libertarian paleo cons in
particular of justin raimondo and people
over there I mean that's his argument
you know he says well it's just too late
we can't let them in because we did [ __ ]
it up and it's our fault that we did
that but we can't let these people in
because in fact they hate us now because
of American foreign policy so there is a
logic to that did you know I I do
respect but my god I mean to actually to
not let people in III can't do it yeah
you can't I don't know what to say
beyond that accepted in general I do
know that open borders and free trade as
you know cause more human liberation and
prosperity than anything else yeah Oh
Annie and I did just no way I can bomb
someone's country and then not let them
in our next conversation I spoke with
health care expert Michael canon of the
Cato Institute I started by asking him
what Trump can do to fulfill his
campaign promise to dismantle Obamacare
he can do four things starting today if
he wanted to he could announce that the
subsidies that a federal judge has ruled
violate the Constitution that the Obama
administration has been giving to
insurers participating in Obamacare he
could say we're gonna respect that
judge's ruling we're not going to appeal
that ruling those subsidies are going to
end on this date certain so insurance
companies you're not going to be getting
those billions of dollars he could say
that the other stream of subsidies those
are the cost-sharing reduction payments
you can say this other stream of
subsidies the reinsurance payments that
the GAO said the Obama administration is
illegally diverting toward to insurance
companies participating on Obamacare
three billion dollars so far he's going
to say the GAO has ruled those were
illegal those payments are going to stop
he could say we are going to fight
vigorously the lawsuits that insurers
has filed against the US government to
try to get even more money to because
they're participating in Obamacare
whereas the Obama administration has
said we might settle them and give the
insurers a big payout he could say we're
going to fight those vigorously the
insurers are going to get nothing and
finally he could say that the exemption
that Congress has been getting from
Obamacare will end on january twentieth
of 2017 you know he does those four
things then I guarantee you Congress is
going to reopen Obamacare uh it in early
2017 and likely repeal it and so but the
reason is that by doing those things by
ending these illegal bailouts and the
illegal waiver that or the illegal
exemption that Congress got from
Obamacare it's going to be building a
lot of pressure in Congress to do
something putting a lot of pressure on
them to do something really just by
implementing Obamacare the way it was
written right uh and showing that is
unsustainable and it's going to collapse
now what should day
do how should they replace Obamacare
well that's going to be that's going to
be the harder part and it's going to be
harder because the dominant Republican
idea right now or I should say one of
the two dominant Republican ideas right
now is basically to replace Obamacare
with Obamacare light a lot of
Republicans including House Speaker Paul
Ryan have coalesced around this idea
that once you get rid of Obamacare you
should create this thing called a health
insurance tax credit where the
government reduces your texts liability
by a set amount if you buy a government
designed health insurance plan but think
about this the government is defining
what kind of health insurance you have
to buy telling you you have to either
buy that or you'll pay more money to the
IRS and because these so-called tax
credits are refundable that means a lot
of people who don't owe money to the IRS
are just going to get a check from the
government so you've got a lot of
redistribution in there you're basically
recreating Obamacare within a Republican
in promoter and does it have it so it
does not have an individual mandate per
se but it really kind of loads the the
scales towards buying they don't call it
a federal mandate but it really is an
individual that day because it exists
it's exactly the same they're there
they're doing it under the taxing under
the taxing power so Chief Justice
Roberts would approve uh and and
creating in a penalty on people who
don't buy a government design plan is
going to give the government it's much
control over your health insurance
policy as it has under Obamacare there's
going to be as much redistribution as
there is under Obamacare and even though
they're even mimicking the centerpiece
of Obamacare which is its pre-existing
condition provisions that's just this is
code for a scheme of government price
controls there Republicans are
advocating that's as Republicans but
conservative think tanks like some folks
at the American Enterprise Institute are
advocating that Republicans mimic
Obamacare's Community Rating price
controls by creating so-called
continuity of coverage price controls
that prohibit insurance companies from
charging actually fair premiums if
people switch plans well so it's kind of
like rent control
for health care almost or rent
stabilization what is the other what is
the other Republican plan and which
would point out that the Republicans
took their sweet time coming up with you
know actual replacement plans but what
what's the other main Republican idea
well this is that you health care has
never been a Republican issue and you
can see it in the ideas that they've put
forward they mimic democratic approaches
to health care so closely that's why I
think the members of Congress who have
introduced their this the second
approach really deserve praise they are
just flake from Republican senator from
Arizona Dave Brad a Republican member of
the House from Virginia no one who
ousted their a majority leader eric
cantor they've introduced a bill that
would expand health savings accounts but
they would expand health savings
accounts in a way that could totally
revamp the way the federal government
taxes health care or more precisely Penn
Eliza's people if they don't buy a
government design plan and in effect
what this what this approach this hasa
expansion approach could do is
effectuate a nine trillion dollar tax
cut nine trillion dollars is the amount
of my earnings and your earnings and
everyone else is earnings if they we
have to surrender to our employer and
let our employer used to choose our
health plan they do that because there
is another penalty and other mandate in
the tax code that says either you give
your employer this money or you have to
pay higher taxes well and by that
approached by that young man approached
in in saying that what you're you're
pointing out that with what our
employers spend on health care we do not
we do not get taxed on as if its regular
compensation so correct so in in
creating the HSA this way we actually
get to continue to spend money on health
care without being taxed on it as
compensation but the the way to
understand that that supposed tax break
is that the federal government is
basically telling you you got to give
thirteen thousand dollars of your income
to your employer you've gotta surrender
that to your employer and let them use
that to choose your health plan because
if you go to an employee or if instead
you want that money is cash you get that
money from your employer's cash we're
going to penalize you by taxing that
money of subjecting it to both payroll
and income taxes so that's a huge tax
penalty unless you gives your employer
control of thirteen thousand dollars of
your income that doesn't sound like a
tax cut to me that's private attacks and
and you add up all that thirteen
thousand dollars across all the workers
over the next ten years it adds up to
nine trillion dollars so what the flake
brat approach would do is it would allow
people to control nine trillion dollars
of their income that they they currently
cannot control in effect a large tax
cost but without increasing their tax
liability to the federal government at
all and then they could choose a health
plan that that that stays with them from
job to job I hope find that they liked
rather than when their employer do they
subject do they subject the health plans
to any kind of certification process to
say that it meets certain minimum
requirements or government mandates
anytime you have any sort of subsidy or
tax preference the government has to
define what is eligible for that tax
preference so if people want to take
their money that thirteen thousand
dollars put into a large HSA large
health savings account and then use it
to buy health insurance tax free yeah
it's got to meet a government definition
of what is it a health insurance policy
that's eligible for tax free HSA
purchases however that's different so
it's similar in concept to the to the
health insurance tax credit I was lying
to the individual mandate but important
in in uh in a couple of or different in
its a couple of very important respects
one of them is that because you would
have the option not to buy health
insurance and save that money
tax free in your large HSA that mandated
or that government definition of what
you of qualified health insurance is
much less scary and because you can do
that because you have that freedom that
definition is going to be less
burdensome because in because providers
and others don't have these won't have
the incentive to lobby Congress to
require you to buy coverage for
acupuncture and and mental health and
alcoholism and drug abuse coverage and
other things issue those types contra
census coverage other things may not
want because they can't be sure that
you're then going to buy that coverage
grab the freedom not to buy it and save
your money tax-free so so does it
completely eliminate the tax codes role
in health care no but it is a dramatic
step toward free markets whereas if you
repeal Obamacare and replace it with
health insurance tax credit then you're
taking one step away from a
government-run system and then take that
same stack step back toward a government
process is there what is your sense
which which policy or which wich
approach is dominant among republicans
or is likely to win any kind of
legislative battle which will include
Democrats as well I think it's really
jump ball at this point because
Republicans you know have not coalesced
around this health insurance tax credit
idea partly because a lot of them sent
sense that this is just Obamacare light
this is just mimic a tanned Obamacare's
major provisions and you know if it's
they fought Obamacare for six years just
to sign just repeal it and then
implement it themselves I think that the
flake brat approach is much more in line
with Republican and conservative and
libertarian principles because it it
builds on something that that
conservatives and Republicans are
already familiar with which is health
savings accounts and as I said before it
does take a step toward a second step
once you repeal Obamacare
yet another step in the direction of
free markets and I think that the more
they look at it the more Republicans
will sense that talk a little bit about
it will end with this you know why you
know remind us of why free markets can
actually improve not only the quality
but the quantity of healthcare now
that's something that has been lost it
seems in many conversations over health
care because you know part of it was
democrats or supporters of Obama care or
of a single-payer plan we're saying we
need the government to pay for this
because it's too expensive people on the
right oftentimes we're saying Obamacare
is going to you know destroy Medicare
itself a single care plate payer what is
the what is the argument about bringing
market forces to to bear on health care
which is often seen as something that is
distinct in its economic structures from
you know buying hamburgers or hotdogs or
something also health care in the United
States is an absolute mess we are paying
a way too much for what we're getting
the prices for medical services are
opaque into high prices for health
insurance are are too high and climbing
too rapidly the worst part is that the
quality of care and the quality of of
health insurance is so poor and
especially with health insurance it's
getting poorer as a result of Obamacare
but the great virtue of the u.s. system
is that because it is so fragmented
there are corner where we don't have one
great day government-run program for
everybody there are corners of the
health care sector where market forces
have been given room to breathe where we
have we have a whole panoply of
government programs and tax preferences
or tax penalties really and and and
mandates and regulations and so forth
that have completely distorted the
market and inhibited market forces but
there are some corners where market
forces have been given room to breed and
they have produced amazing things
amazing innovation
that showed that markets can reduce
prices and improve quality at the same
time what sit down okay you know exit
two examples out in California some
insurers did an experiment where they
said to people who are getting
colonoscopies or hip and knee
replacements here's how much of quality
hospital charges for this stuff and
that's how much we're going to pay you
and if you want to pay more than that
you're on the hook for that so these
patients who before or we're totally
insensitive to the cost of their hip
knee replacements and colonoscopies well
sudden asking their providers about it
and just making the patient's
cost-conscious in that way caused price
competition among hospitals and that and
and cause prices to fall by an average
of about sixteen thousand dollars for
hip and knee replacements so those are
substantial shows you how inflated the
prices are because of all these
government interventions and how much
market forces can bring the prices for
these services down another example is
in the market where insurers but or
where consumers buy health insurance
directly from insurance companies prior
to Obama care insurance companies had
been innovating and they were they
offered by 2008 they offered in 25
states a product that says to people
look come to us well under well apply
for an insurance plan will quote your
premium and then you can either buy that
insurance plan enroll in it immediately
or four one fifth of that premium so
instead of paying mini $5,000 you pay
one thousand dollars a year you can buy
the right to enroll in that plan and it
is anytime you want and roll that
underlying health insurance policy
anytime you want no matter how sick you
get in the meantime so if you pay that
twenty percent of the premium and uh and
then you get cancer you can enroll on
that health plan saying the same premium
that healthy people pay I call it
pre-existing conditions insurance and
imagine how that would have
revolutionized the the market for health
insurance for say college students or
people who are generally healthy don't
fit they may have enough socked away for
an acute medical episode but would want
to buy health insurance if they got a
chronic long-term illness imagine how
much more of the healthcare sector would
be due
toward the cash market where you have
some of the cost consciousness that we
saw driving down prices in that
experiment in California these are the
corners of the health care sector where
market forces have shown that they can
make health care better and more
affordable and more secure and that is
why we need to repeal Obamacare and
that's why we need to replace it with
expanded health savings accounts and
then not even stop there we need to
reform the Medicare program for the mint
reform the Medicaid program and and and
keep on pulling government back beat
because the more we do the more we're
going to help the most vulnerable the
repeal and replacement of Obamacare
would be a bright spot but will
president Trump follow through on his
disturbing law and order rhetoric and
all it implies for civil liberties and
criminal justice reform I talked to la
base defense attorney Ken white who has
a large following at the Pope at law
blog about what a Justice Department
headed up by someone like Rudy Giuliani
might look like there's a lot of reason
for concern it can get bad and it can
get bad on a number of levels first of
all they're setting the priority for
federal prosecutions across the country
you know there are a lot of us attorneys
out there and they have very limited
resources unlike the various da offices
which basically have to take all comers
you know if you shoot someone they don't
get to decide we're not going to use our
resources on this this year the US
Attorneys offices are very choosy about
what federal prosecutions they do in
different districts and different
administrations have had different
priorities so you've seen
administration's that have been
concerned for instance about civil
rights prosecutions about federal
prosecutions of officers that violate
suspects rights and of vigorous white
collar prosecutions of misconduct in the
financial sector those are the ones that
all us X AOS a love because those are
the people with money of course right
but you also had times when Department
of Justice really revs up the incentives
for higher numbers and smaller cases so
you could have a much bigger in emphasis
on
immigration cases on prosecuting people
who are smugglers prosecuting people who
came here after being deported
prosecuting people who are involved in
manufacturing false identity documents
and you can certainly think that that's
good to do that the thing is that
federal prosecutions of that sort of
thing or a drop in the ocean unless we
spend massive amounts of money they're
never going to have much more of a dent
on immigration crime than they currently
have on drug crime and the other problem
is every time you shift priorities you
take away money from types of
prosecutions you might want to see more
of so when you hear complaining that you
know no one in the financial industry
was prosecuted after the 2008 crash well
they're not likely to be if you have US
Attorneys offices where the white-collar
crime is minimally staffed but then you
also have direct ideological type things
it's certainly possible to use the
Department of Justice to go after an
enemies list you know we have in mr.
Trump someone who suggested that he'd
put his opponent in jail and he's
certainly capable of do we don't do you
as a lawyer are you do you take that
seriously or is that just kind of a
barstool bully letting off steam yeah I
don't know and I don't think we'll know
till it happens I think it's possible
it's just steam I think it's possible
that he'll do something but I mean the
Obama administration showed us with the
IRS miss behavior that it's perfectly
possible to manipulate the parts of the
government to harass or selectively
prosecute different people based on
ideology it's also possible to have what
I would characterize is sort of bizarre
priorities like you know Ashcroft is
Attorney General famously trying to ramp
up all the obscenity prosecutions and
you know during the Bush administration
there were a fair amount of emphasis on
you know finding the most out
just porn you could tricking you know
trying to get someone in a very
conservative community to buy it and
then federally prosecuting that person
and then and then losing the case I mean
I guess they won one high-profile case
and then they lost another with that
they bizarrely took against john
stagliano lay a porn producer who has
been a donor to reason fiendish but then
they tried it in in Washington DC and
when it came to the jury that the judge
wouldn't even let the jury delivered
they he wouldn't even let the stylianos
people present a defense because it was
like you haven't even made a case here
but yeah and but but but that's what you
get right like that's the president can
be you know they appoint an attorney
general and the Attorney General you
know can start saying you know what we
need more prosecution of kittens Mexican
kittens and chihuahuas they're coming
across the border and that's going to
have a major effect I assume then that
you are cautiously pessimistic given
that Trump in the you know the rhetoric
he talked a lot about crime in the
streets which is mostly in his head you
know crime is at or near historic lows
and most major metropolitan areas and
throughout the country but then also
talking a lot about immigration that
seems like something that he might be
investing a lot of energy and power into
well he has a relatively little
influence on crime in the streets in the
sense of that's overwhelmingly policed
by state and local forces which most
likely he knows he doesn't control and
you know he can certainly have a policy
agenda on that trying to get Congress to
give more tax money to police
departments you know he can around the
bully pulpit he can even try to do
things like use the mechanism of the
Justice Department to go after groups
like black lives matter on the theory
that they're somehow part of a national
conspiracy against police which I think
would be very abusive whether or not you
agree with everything black lives matter
does so the mechanisms are there but i
think that the generally
the system trans more towards
dysfunction and competence that it does
towards effective manipulation and my
hope is more of a law and order regime
where he talks big and has big dreams
but can't really accomplish much of
anything and I'm hoping that's a more
realistic outcome then general genuinely
Nick Sounion let's use the mechanisms to
go after people or you know like the IRS
recently against against conservative
groups now do you think you know with
one of the interesting stories about
this campaign really is the role that
WikiLeaks might have played in
convincing people are hardening people's
convictions that Hillary Clinton is if
not quite doing illegal things as kind
of a shady character and a liar who will
say one thing to a private audience and
something else to to a public one what
what happens like are we in a world now
where if the government starts to go
after conservative I guess maybe in this
case it would be liberal or progressive
groups kind of in a nick Sounion fashion
and Trump has certainly you know kind of
flashed you know flashes lag on that a
little bit will it be easier or harder
to find out because we do one of the
things that this this election may have
hinged on is a kind of involuntary
transparency that freaks people out for
all sorts of reasons I think it freaks
out individuals it freaks out
corporations of freaks that hold
governments do you feel like we'll be
better prepared to look for that kind of
pattern of prosecution or the goods like
the secret emails that prove something I
don't think well I think would be in a
worse place and this is why I think
we're much more used to the government
and the mechanisms of law enforcement
using leaks than being held back by them
so you know one of my pet peeves with
journalism is is the tendency to accept
leaks from law enforcement to talk about
defendants or suspects and not report on
the story that is the
act that law enforcement is leaking this
to hurt the defendant help the case
which to me is part of the story I think
that will continue to see leakers and
the priests the press they leaked it to
be willing to accept leaks uncritically
and that's generally going to work to
the favor of law enforcement because
there's this mentality that you know
it's what's in the leak that's news and
the fact of the leak or how it happened
or why it happened isn't news let me
give you a little example of that Nick
that he always thumbs up my feeling
about the relationship between law
enforcement in the press my partner
represented a controversial local
politician always in the news and the
DA's office charged him and showed up to
arrest him in his house early one Friday
morning and of course they tipped off
the Los Angeles Times the time sent a
reporter and a photographer but they got
their little late the local politician
was already in cuffs in the car the
reporter complained about it but you
know traffic traffic is Helen Hawaii I
mean so yeah you guys are early right
sure uh they walked the guy back into
his house and then turned him around and
walked him back in cuffs into the car so
that they could get photographs of it
and the Times ran it uh without
mentioning that they had reenacted the
scene correct i goes to the to depress
the money shot of the perp walk was news
and the willingness of the cops to stage
it for them was not news Jesus I think
we need both a public in a media that is
willing to question that read of things
because sometimes in when holy uh in any
number of other cases and just to remind
people when holy worked at Los Alamos I
believe was that he was a Chinese at
chinese american or chinese descent and
he was fingered during was at the bush
years or the late [ __ ] was the lake
clinton years right Wesley was a late
Clinton years yeah
traffic and giving away secrets to the
Chinese government and it looked you
know he was you know putting the slammer
and all of that or was going to be and
it turned out to be a completely
evidence-free case against him that
seemed rooted in kind of racial or
ethnic paranoia we I end and basically
the government used judiciously the
media to whip up public opinion against
him and ruin his chance of ever getting
a fair trial if it had gotten that far
or you know Richard Jewell uh described
as the uniboob and through leaks as the
guy who committed the atlanta olympic
bombing when of course he had nothing to
do with it uh and it goes on and on all
the time i think the media is willing to
be used as a tool and is too wedded to
the idea that well if it's a fact
they're giving me at the fact of giving
me in the public has to know when
there's no ethical or practical or
political weight to the fact that
they're leaking it to me and I question
that promise yeah and I guess to come
back to your original question I'm very
skeptical that right now we will see
leaks that will help defend against a
out of control Justice Department as
opposed to assist it I mean I and even
though the press I mean I guess in two
ways you know the press itself and you
could see this on the every cable
network with the exception of Fox last
night I mean people almost weeping I
thought Brian Williams was you know
going to pull a bud Dwyer at some point
on MSNBC you know they were very mad you
know when very upset by the rise of
Trump they dislike Trump but they will
not that will not or maybe it's just the
talking heads but that won't filter into
an operational shift where the press
actually becomes more of a watchdog
organization rather than a kind of lap
dog in a blur of government overreach
right and I don't see anything from
WikiLeaks that indicates to me that
they're likely to be even-handed either
and do you think I mean this is an
interesting question that Trump on us
level and his his supporters they they
rose to prominence and ultimately to
electoral victory by saying you know
what we're calling [ __ ] on the media
the mainstream media the lamestream
media with the exception of the great
good journalists at Breitbart are all
full of beans and we don't believe a
word you say that is not going to
transfer into a broad-based skepticism
of what President Trump starts enacting
I assume I I don't think people's minds
are going to work that way I think that
he has very successfully trained his
followers to you know think that if it's
anti-trump if it's not supportive of
Trump that it's not credible and that's
going to be very useful to him as a
president and I hope it doesn't last too
long because I think it's very dangerous
to be that uncritical I think Obama has
enjoyed that type of protection for some
time I think the Clintons did too to
some extent and you know if you get a
sufficiently aggressive president with
that type of following that completely
disregards the media well it's the
matter for concern talk a little bit
about you know people are already
throwing around the idea of Rudy
Giuliani a former mayor of New York
former federal prosecutor who in many
ways kind of you know perfected the perp
walk on white collar crime in New York
back in the day as attorney general or
chris Christie who it would be
interesting that Governor of New Jersey
who is under all sorts of attack for his
involvement in various skeevy business
most most prominently bridgegate where
some of his people have been found
guilty of shutting that a bridge in
order to screw over a political opponent
of Christie's so you know if we get a
real so was a prosecutor if i'm not
mistaken but you know if we get a Rudy
Giuliani Attorney General is that a is
that a real problem well it's I think
the priorities and the agenda are more
of a problem than the personality
someone like Rudy Giuliani's try
me as someone like Trump who's likely to
do a lot of you know big showy
flourishes and that will be unpleasant
but that the thing we should really keep
our eye on is where there were their
prosecution priorities what cases do
they bring where they shift the
Department of Justice's resources I mean
Giuliani yeah he's the king of the perp
walk he he strikes me as the type of AG
who could do something like you know
it's typical when you you're negotiating
with the government for a client who
hasn't been charged yet to arrange her a
surrender and you know I could see
Giuliani doing something like you know
no surrenders everyone gets arrested and
everyone gets the perp walk that would
be the sort of classic showy look how
tough we are [ __ ] thing to do that
people like that enjoy in terms of the
substance I mean I'm more afraid of a
quiet efficient capable self-controlled
Attorney General completely devoted to a
bad agenda than I am to you know kind of
a nudge like Rudy Giuliani you know why
don't we close with and I realize I'm
going off script here a little bit but
Janet Reno the who was either the
longest or second longest serving
Attorney General in American history
recently died she served under the Bill
Clinton in the 90s and was pretty
terrible on a whole host of issues I
suspect that you agree with that when
you look at recent attorneys general are
there any people and let's define recent
by a you know going back to the you know
the bicentennial year there or something
you know are there any attorneys general
who you think actually perform the
function in the way that it is
constitutionally intended where you know
they actually help the federal
government run more efficiently and
they're not just kind of settling scores
or following their own obsessions into
you know weird and disturbing places I
don't know if I would hold up any and
say gosh I wish this were the Attorney
General again I think
number of them have shown flashes of
Independence I mean certainly we I I
guess I have a soft spot for Reno
because I met her and she gave me an
award but you were your and there you
were attacking journalists for you know
going soft on a government that gives
them access but exactly so but she
certainly had a very troubling history
both of the beginning in the end of her
term she did do some things that were
not on Clinton's agenda she did permit
some investigations that the Clintons
didn't want which is the type of
Independence I'd like to see an attorney
general you know I would like to and
there was even that moment of somebody
like john ashcroft as awful as he was in
so many ways he was on his deathbed or
recovering from surgery and he refused
to sign papers that were kind of pushed
in his face right that would have
allowed for all sorts of kind of carte
blanche on bush administration hijinks
well exactly and that's why I think that
I guess that would be the scariest part
of a Rudy Giuliani type figure because I
would see Giuliani is likely just
Trump's creature I wouldn't only see him
standing up to trump or exercising
independent judgment or unist
contradicting him and that would be
disappointed so I prefer that he I don't
think it's going to happen but for the
Trump find somebody the sort of people
who might question his opinion is there
a do you have a historical attorney
general that you love dearly gosh I i
I'm sure if he gave me tone I might come
up with one but I don't have work for
you you know what you're sounding a lot
like Gary Johnson about world leaders
where I thought you would have five six
seven people you know at the top of your
hands and now I'm trying to like
Nicholas katzenback you know right and
now I'm just throwing out names and he
was terrible right day I think he was
LBJ's bagman for a while yeah well I
mean they're all sorts of terrible ones
i mean i guess you could say that anyone
who refused to do something
illegal uh is worth considering I mean
Richardson and Ruggles house both had
their problems but they resigned during
the Saturday night massacre rather than
take Nixon's order to fire the special
prosecutor so that at least was a moment
of integrity if the Attorney General
almost always disappoints libertarians
what about Supreme Court appointments
and how concerned should we be with
Trump's utter disregard for civil
liberties and the separation of powers
Georgetown Law Professor Randy Barnett
says the rise of Trump just might
inspire liberals and progressives to
start believing in limiting the power
and reach of government my pitch is
simply it's time to stop thinking that
you guys are always going to be in power
because you're not I didn't understand
it seemed foolish to abandon the rule of
law because you somehow think that
you're always going to be in power with
and not to put yourself in the position
of being under the thumb of some other
guy and Trump is almost perfect
unfortunately actually fortunately for
the country he's probably not the
radical crazy person that he himself
makes himself out to be because that's
just the character he played during this
campaign and when he plays the character
of president it's likely to be a
different character than the one of
campaign of the candidate but if he
really were that scary crazy person
that's all the better chaya gai to get
the left to consider restoring the rule
of law checks and balances to protect
them from people like this yeah I talked
a bit about the Supreme Court we have
you know anywhere between zero or
negative replacements ago depending on
if Trump even wants to you know staff up
after attrition on the Supreme Court to
you know it seems like everybody could
be leaving now you know what are what
are your thoughts about the Supreme
Court and Trump's appointees and I'll
point out that you showed up on Gary
Johnson's less the Libertarian Party
candidate Supreme Court list did that
make you feel good or did that make you
feel angry
I went I went and I went shopping for
robes because I wanted to get one before
they wrap yeah that's a well you know I
think hopefully you haven't worn it
outside so you can return it right that
yeah yes a four cent richer they had a
30-day return policy so what what what
do you think this does to the future you
know what what are the stakes at the
Supreme Court and where do you think
Trump has given out at least two lists
of potential of the types of justices he
wants to appoint what do you think of
that is there any any real philosophy or
ideology there that's worth
understanding this this was always
strongest argument for Trump it remains
the strongest argument for Trump I just
looked at the list this morning it was
obviously other reporters have been in
touch with me and it's a good list of
the I don't know everybody on the list
but of you know maybe a third what half
of the people and of the third and a
half of people i know i think they're
good people i think they're good and and
and look the way the president the way i
was explaining my students to be the way
this works is all presidents outsource
in right in modern times all presidents
out swords judicial picking to the
interest groups that really care about
that issue presidents have their own
policy agendas for Trump is going to be
trade and immigration it's not the court
and that gets outsourced to people in
the coalition caroli about it and this
would be people who would be loosely
associated let's say with the federalist
society in in the left side it's it's
think progress and and and and Alliance
for justice and those folks people for
the american way though people that are
you know care about this stuff on the
Left that's who gets to say who know
proposed people and and the people that
have been comfort the best thing to say
about Trump the best thing you could
always say about Trump is all people
including the two people he named during
the debate were good people and so
therefore he's listening to people who
know good people how did he knows him
the president's never know them tonko
the people he's listening to our
apparently node with a good people are
and and by good people
you define a good person when you're
talking about a potential Supreme Court
justice what are what are the contours
of that well here's a let me begin by
saying the prom ? in my mind and and
this has always been a question about
Trump and even the good people and what
makes a good people there's two kinds of
conservative justices there are the
constitutional original list justices
and then there are the judicial
restraint judicial conservative justices
that believe in restraint and for way
too long Republicans have been outright
seeking the judicial restraint judges
who will defer to Congress and refer to
the President himself and in recent
years there's no strong movement in
favor of constitutional original lyst
justices more in the mold of Justice
Thomas but perhaps even more so than
hehe him and this list contains people
who probably are liberal both I can't be
sure % sure which they are that's what
you need confirmation hearings forward
by the way and but they're promising and
I think if you it would be a sad
situation if he appoints traditional
restraint conservatives because they're
the people that gave us Obamacare
they're the people that say the new deal
is okay and we just have to hold the
line here and there and I think
Republicans by and large turned away
from that and my hope is that that the
the people who will be vetting these
nominees will also care about
originalism at least as much as they
care about restraint and that would be a
huge improvement to the Supreme Court
over what we have today so there is a
potential I'm not promising to you Nick
but there is a potential upside to what
happened yesterday for Constitution of
the United States do you worry at all I
you know we've talked touch on a very
lightly about the libel laws and whatnot
Donald Trump like Hillary Clinton in
different ways you know attacked the
First Amendment at various points he
said I want to open up the libel laws so
I can sue the New York Times or jeff
bezos who of amazonas whence the
Washington Post when they print stories
that I don't like about myself at one
point he actually said in the same
weekend in December that Hillary Clinton
said that we've got to start taking a
parts of the internet to rid it of sites
or platforms that allow jihadists to
kind of meet and mingle Trump said
exactly the same thing he was and and
with his patented kind of lack of
understanding he talked about how he was
going to get Bill Gates to somehow shut
down parts of the internet I remember
that do you worry about you know kind of
basic constitutional rights under under
a trump presidency particularly for
things like free speech and free
assembly and you know the First
Amendment issues really excuse me of
course I do the reason why I wasn't
supporting Trump as I said to my
students today you know there was an
advantage being against both of his
candidates and that is no matter who won
today there would be good news and that
is the other person lost so i was i was
actually much more well suited to be in
a better mood than most people around
here because i was against both of them
so you're absolutely right there's a
very good reason to be concerned about
him and then the question is what is
really going to be within his wheelhouse
something that he's actually going to
have an interest in that he's not going
to be tied up doing other things and
that there won't be other people around
him to stop him if in fact he does take
interest in these things from doing that
stuff and that's going to depend on his
administration as much as it is on
heaven yes we should be concerned about
it and we should be watchful and and
your your banking or I mean you're
you're assuming and I think there's good
reason to that he's kind of articulated
trade and immigration has his the things
that he is most preoccupied with which
of course and particularly with
immigration I mean what you know what
are the what are the constitutional
challenges to his promises to and you
know they change over time but to round
up you know 11 or 12 million people plus
maybe another 4 million kids who are US
citizens and say they have to go but i
think that at the end of the day he has
intimated so many different times that
he is prepared to negotiate in bargain
and reach a deal and he's actually
favored partial amnesty and at times in
the past include
very recently I think the people who are
counting on him to be the eminent the
immigration hardliner that they would
like to imagine him to be are going to
be disappointed just because I don't
think Donald Trump cares that much about
any particular issue in his heart is a
New York liberal Democrat who managed to
win the Republican Party is a reaction
as a reality TV star and so he ran on
that issue I believe that's the shoe he
broke he will be tougher on immigration
that Hillary would have been the first
part but I think it's going to be a
negotiated effort to enforce existing
immigration laws which is not as radical
as it sounds to enforce existing
immigration laws I think you might have
much bigger concern actually on the
great area because that's where you know
I don't really I'm not a real expert on
trade Nick so you might want to
interview someone else about this but
from what I understand the president has
been given by Congress a tremendous
amount of authority in the course of
enforcing and negotiating trade
agreements and to the extent the
president has discretion this president
will exercise it and this is something
he really does seem to care that and and
hidden his trade policy could end up
being disastrous yeah and of course that
brings it back to the starting point of
what is the relationship between the
president and congress and obviously
hillary clinton was also is talking in
anti-trade line pulling it off of bernie
sanders and what not and maybe this is
the moment where the spine of Congress
will be stiffened to demand that they
have more say in trade policy and that
it moves in a in a more libertarian
direction maybe I'm not I'm not
optimistic about this at all I mean
we'll have to see you know you're the
optimist I am the odd I always accuse me
of being an optimist too so we so we
both are optimists but on this
particular issue i'm not sure i see an
optimistic scenario here other than the
fact that the consequences of what he
says he wants to do are so predictably
onerous that they're not likely to
happen but who the heck knows we've had
we've had we've had smooth Holly in the
past we could have smooth Holly again
if you find the prospect of Donald Trump
mainstreaming protectionist trade policy
daunting and you should his statements
on education policy are cause for real
optimism education reformer Lisa Graham
Keegan didn't vote for Trump but she
says the president-elect has been
forceful if vague in his support for
increasing school choice it is a good
thing from an education point of view
and in fact that was like voted against
myself actually because he has been good
on these issues in a very vague 35,000
maybe hundred thousand foot level right
I like school choice I like to see
control so that's sort of where it
stopped and started and stopped I guess
but I do know you know as people like
Gerard Robinson and Bill Evers who are
good minds and practice people and you
know he's got some smart folks around so
good I mean it is good i think you know
I the what has to happen at the
Department of Education is they've got
to quit trying to be to Congress the
Congress did actually a very nice
bipartisan job of rolling back a lot of
the No Child Left Behind overreached
trimming that giving it back to the
states and then the Department of
Education was sort of in the process of
overreaching when the election hit
yesterday so wait tell me tell me a
little bit about tell me a little bit
about that so Congress rolls back a
bunch of the mandates that are involved
in No Child Left Behind which of course
was cooked up by Ted Kennedy and George
Bush Canada you know and other
bipartisan malefactors but you say a lot
of that was peeled back and then but the
Department of Education was not with
that program they were still kind of
forcing it well they were through
regulation they were coming up with the
set of rules as to how to implement this
roll back which is ironic right let us
help you with a huge set of rules decide
how to liberate yourself so the
intention that the Congress put forward
was basically look states are in charge
here yes you have to say how your
schools are doing that is a good idea
people have a right to know whether
these are functional but you all do that
and
let us know how you plan on doing it and
you need these markers but you have to
tell us how different groups of kids are
doing etc so all of that would have been
great and then the regulatory what
looked like a lot of overreach coming
was well okay in concept you can do that
but we want you to keep statistics in
the following way which basically would
force a whole lot of different practices
and I know that sounds sort of vague but
basically it was trying to stick a lot
of the regulation that got taken out
back in and there were bunch of stories
as recently as this week about Lamar
Alexander and other thurs who really
worked on this saying no that wasn't our
intention and I think you would have
seen a real war had had trouble not been
what what was Hillary proposing on the
trail and this I know from years ago in
it takes a village he actually which
came out in the late 90s just as charter
schools were starting up she had kind
words about charter school and a bad
school choice in it takes a village and
but on this campaign during this
campaign she came out pretty forcefully
against charter schools and against
school choice didn't you she did so her
village was the teachers union this year
was the village that it took I mean she
went she went to ground and it's too bad
because yet she and former President
Clinton had been early advocates for I
just be able to bring their skills to
the market which is what a charter
school is and so that's a shame and it
was frightening actually and I I think
we would have seen huge roll backs in
progress in marketplace education that
really is taking hold in a lot of places
like my beautiful Arizona so and it is
making a positive academic difference
that's the good news yeah talk about
that was scary so yeah there was a
recent New York Times story that talked
about you know not all charter schools
are great but these ones are and they
tend to demand a lot from the students
is that you know are we I mean is the
Trump victory in a kind of interesting
way it seemed as if progressives
who dislike school choice they dislike
public charter schools they dislike any
kind of messing with the status quo
other than giving more money to existing
kind of conventional schools it seems
they were starting to get the upper hand
on a lot of kind of propaganda John
Oliver on this last week tonight did an
extended attack on charter schools as
kind of being riddled with scandals and
and lousy results some of which is true
do you feel like between Trump winning
and you know the New York Times coming
out and saying you know what these
charter schools are actually helping the
most at-risk children predictably and in
positive ways is this a does it seem
like it's it's dawn breaking for the
school choice movement you know I hope a
couple of different songs break here
Nick because a couple of things happened
so yes the president-elect is elected so
Tom gets elected that is the protocol
choices move the other things that
happened though were in Massachusetts a
potential cap on charter school did not
pass in fact was hugely slammed by
suburban parents and in Georgia they had
sought to create an achievement district
where they could sort of liberate a set
of schools that were doing poorly and
try to get them to be better for me what
I hope we learn as a Republican Party is
that there is a reason that your
education policies to turn on
marketplaces and what people want you
know the everybody lauded the
Massachusetts charter school system
because it was such high qualities or
the Harvard of the American charter
school system but like Harvard very few
people could get in there they're like
10 0 12 schools in Arizona we have over
600 and we grow at ten percent a year
and it took us 20 years but the charge
sector in Arizona is consistently
outperforming the traditional system why
because they can close themselves down
they can let people go if they're not
performing making all the things you
need to do to stay at high quality well
that is a result of relying on and
believing that at the end of the day the
demands parents will prevail we'll get
you a better system and I just feel like
we kind of got co-opted by
for planning you know once we figured
out how some people were doing these
things right have some authorizers are
getting it right we try to impose that
on everybody that's an incorrect
response right and so I so I mean it's
really it's got it you mean just like
you know you always hear this about tech
tech industries and and other businesses
that have to adapt or die the charter
school model or the school choice model
has to constantly be reinventing itself
in relationship to the demands of
parents and and having confidence that
that process will turn out a better
product and better experiences for kids
yeah that's right educators actually do
know what they are doing and the other
thing is you cannot limit access to new
schools to new public schools to
low-income families you absolutely have
to incentivize that but the reason we're
successful in Arizona is because wealthy
families also have their kids in public
charter schools families who pull
political levers if you sit down with
the chattering classes in Phoenix or any
part of Arizona and you ask how many of
you have your child or grandchild in a
charter school about half that room
going to raise a pan and so it's so
widely dispersed among opinion leaders
that it's politically stable when you
isolate these things you know Milton
Friedman programs that are determined to
be strictly for the poor will inevitably
be poor programs when the rest of the
public besides you don't get the money
right you can't make these things
charity they have to be systemic so you
know I'm excited about that Nick I don't
know this man I don't know if Trump you
know understands markets well enough to
understand me understand market yeah if
you hate Wally but it yeah there but a
lot of people were saying you know hello
a lot of his money comes from cutting
deals with local governments and getting
subsidies etc I mean it's it's worrying
and certainly he's not he doesn't have
to choose between you know rent payment
and school tuition or anything like that
what what is the role of the Secretary
of Education a couple of names have come
have been floated one is Bill
evers-williams endeavors who you
mentioned before who's been in the
libertarian movement and the school
choice movement and
even the free education movement for
decades another is ben Carson and that's
kind of a head-scratcher because ben
Carson yeah you know that I mean he's a
retired neurosurgeon so exactly what he
would be able to do but what is the
principal role of the Secretary of
Education as you see what what you know
how can they do good and how can they do
bad I think the number one thing that
person can do well and I do think he'll
ever is the other person who didn't
mention is Gerard Robinson definitely
part of their transition team as well so
heaven he has been a state school
superintendent great guide so it is the
role to give voice to the president's
ideology here I always think that's the
most important piece you are the
mouthpiece if you're in that role of the
president united states and in this case
his view about what should be happening
in education across the country i
believe at this juncture and if people
did not get the message that things
should not be coming out of Washington
they were asleep between nine at night
and three this morning I mean I think
that this administration has a grand
opportunity to roll this back I'm not
somebody who believes you just do away
with the Department of Education all of
that regulation is still in the lodge
ikut manage someone so what just managed
to the benefit of freedom right managed
it to the benefit of the people who are
actually doing this work in states and
encourage state offices to do the same I
I believe that would be powerful in this
administration I believe there are
plenty of people who could help him do
that and they're certainly plenty of us
who would help right this is this would
be a breath of fresh air and it's not as
though we don't have models going on
right now all over the country really
great examples of things that are
actually working quite well and actually
seeing gains for kids so there's a lot
of actually operating an office that has
to happen there I would hope they cut
the size of that thing down I think
there's a lot of stuff that should not
be happening there and like to put a
little hiring freeze and do the country
run right send people back into the edge
but the idea is that if if we believe in
local schools or or that the people
closest to a situation our best kind of
informed and empower to fix things or
address things then that's the
department of education should be
turning more control over to state and
local services right yeah I think that's
right i mean there's gentleness
regulatory entity upon regulatory entity
and education I'm you certainly not
lacking we're not going to miss anybody
if a layer falls out so lots of people
voted to be responsible for these things
at the state level at the district level
at the charter board authorized by the
level I mean it we've got folks so I
think we don't need that extraordinary
level there in the federal office except
for those things when we've agreed on a
national basis we really ought to be
pushing one of those a special education
I believe that's really important one of
them is very portraits I believe that's
a great national cause but the
implementation of those programs ought
to be left to the states
and we'll leave it there I want to thank
Lisa Graham Keegan Randy Barnett Ken
white Michael cannon and thad Russell
and thanks for listening to the recent
podcasts we're going to be having more
of these conversations in the coming
week so please subscribe at itunes and
while you're there rate and review us
and let us know how we're doing and who
you'd like to hear from for reason I'm
Nick Gillespie